The first nine most common questions
asked by non-Muslim. The first was
that jihad
is any war fought by any Muslim for any
reason. Whether it be for money, whether
it be for power, whether it be for
language, whether it be for land,
whether it be for wealth, the
non-Muslims think that any war fought by
any Muslim is called as jihad.
Number two,
the second most common misconception is
that Muslim the fundamentalist, the
extremist.
The third most common misconception is
Muslim the terrorist.
The fourth most common misconception is
Islam was spared by the sword. The fifth
most common question asked by non-Muslim
Islam is why does Islam permit a man to
have more than one wife? The sixth most
common question is if Islam permits a
man to have more than one wife, why does
Islam not permit a woman to have more
than one husband? The seventh most
common misconception about Islam amongst
the non-Muslim is that why does Islam
subjugate the woman by keeping her
behind the wheel.
The eighth most common misconception
amongst non-Muslim regarding Islam is
that if Islam is against idol worship
then why do Muslims worship the Cabba
five times a day when they offer salah?
And the ninth reply that we discussed
yesterday
regarding the ninth most common question
asked by non-Muslims regarding Islam is
that why does Islam not allow the
non-Muslims to enter the sacred city of
Mecca. Inshallah today we'll discuss the
remaining 11 most common misconception
or the most common questions asked by
non-Muslim regarding Islam.
The 10th
most common question
asked by the non-Muslim
regarding Islam is that why does Islam
permit a Muslim to have non-wage food
which involves the killing of animals?
Isn't killing of animals a ruthless act?
So why does Islam permit a Muslim to
have nonv?
Before I give a before I give the reply
to this question, let me tell you that a
Muslim can be a very good Muslim even by
being a pure vegetarian.
Eating nonveg in Islam is not far. It's
not far. So a Muslim can be a very good
Muslim even by being a pure vegetarian.
But since Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
the Quran gives permission for the
Muslims to have nonwitch food then why
should they not have it? Allah says the
Quran in surah maida chapter number 5
verse number one that
oh you believe lawful for for you for
food are
all for fooded animals with the
exception name. Allah is telling us in
the Quran in surah maida chter 5 verse
number one that oh you believe
lawful for you are food of all forooted
animals except with those
which are named those which are
prohibited mentioned in the Quran the
hadith besides these all for-footed
animals are lawful Allah says in the
Quran in surah chapter number 16 verse
number 5 that verily he's made the
cattle for you from which you derive is
warm in it are various benefits and of
the meat you can eat. Allah says in
surah m chapter number 23 verse number
21 verily in the cattle is an
instructive sign for you give you to
drink from what is within the belly and
in it are various benefits and of the
meat you can eat. So there are various
places in the Quran that permits us to
have non-veg food. So if Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala gives us permission, then why
should we not have it? And today science
tells us that in the non-witch food,
it's a good wholesome food. Today
science tells us that the human body
requires 21 different types of amino
acids.
From these 21 amino acids, 12 are
produced by the body itself. So nine
amino acids are required to be given in
the external food that we take. These
nine amino acids are called as essential
amino acids. The non- which food whether
it be mutton, whether it be chicken,
whether it be fish, they contain all the
nine essential amino acids. And any food
which contains all nine essential amino
acid is called as a wholesome food.
And in meat
there is nasin, there's iron, vitamin B,
various sources of minerals, vitamin,
amino acid. It's healthy. I had a debate
with
Rashmi by Zaviri who was the president
of the Indian vegetarian congress and he
challenged me for a debate and the topic
of the debate was is non-veg food
permitted or prohibited for a human
being and for more details on nonv
that's in detail you can watch that
debate it is hilarious